hello everybody and welcome to this
presentation on
quickly deploying explainable ai
dashboards my name is uh dyke i work at
the uefa which is a dutch
government agency which is responsible
for over seeing and administering a
large part of the dutch uh
welfare state uh i work here as
as a data scientist and i'm working
to get machine learning and models into
production in order to help
our citizens get better services uh
and often like i ran into this issue
that a lot of people are often afraid of
machine learning models of algorithms of
models and what they would do and so it
would be it was very useful to be able
to explain
to people exactly what these models were
doing uh and in order to make this
easier i basically
developed this app item package called
explainer dashboard which makes it
really easy to build your own
explainable ai dashboards
in order to explain exactly what your
machine models are doing so that's what
i'll be presenting today
just a quick outline for today so i'm
going to start with a quick demo to
really show you how easy it is to build
this stuff basically
two lines of code uh and then i'm going
to give you
a review of you okay like what does this
default explain your dashboard look like
um then i'm going to go into
a bit of background like why would you
want such a such a dashboard how does it
help you in your work
as a data scientist working in for
example a government agency
or in a regulated industry
or really for in any organization where
you need to explain exactly
what your model is doing and then
finally we're going to finish off with
showing how you can build your own
custom designed explainer dashboards
which are not specifically tailored for
your own
project model and situation so let's
start
all right so let's build an explainer
dashboard
so here i'm inside a jupiter notebook
and of course uh first thing you need to
do as a data scientist is fit a model
uh in order to fit a model uh we need
some data
so let's get the train data and testing
data uh
and then fit a random forest model here
we go this is on the
uh the italic data that we all know and
love
uh okay so now we have this model fitted
and we'd like to explain exactly
what it's doing uh to maybe a manager
maybe
a regulator or somebody else uh so how
to do this
so one simple way of doing it is uh by
launching an explainer dashboard
in order to do that you first need to
wrap your model inside
and max player instance
uh so that's as easy as this so now you
have an
explainer instance and that's able to
spit out
all kinds of plots that allow you to
investigate the model
for example if you want to look at the
performance of this classification model
you can simply plot the
the confusion matrix
um however as you can see here uh
explainer doesn't know
the the names of the labels for the
positive class in the negative class so
this diffusion matrix is maybe not as
informative as it could be
so in order to remedy that we can
actually pass a whole bunch of
descriptions to the explainer which
means that the graph
will all look a bit better and be a bit
more easy to explain
to a lay person so here we added the
label survived and not survived which is
the outcome of the classifier for a
authentic data set okay so now we have
an explainer object which is able to
spit out
[Music]
graphs and figures and so now we only
need to build an explainer dashboard
around this
uh that is able to use those graphs to
make an interactive dashboard
and basically this is all you need to do
you simply wrap the explainer in an
explainer dashboard instance and then
run the instance
so here you go we need to do a few
calculations and we're up and running
so here we have it so here we have a an
explainer dashboard
uh with seven different tabs
all showing different aspects of your
model and explaining different
parts of your model and
so let's have a go have a look and go
through all these seven tabs so you have
an idea like
what kind of uh what kind of analysis
you can do with this with such a
result explainer dashboard uh so the
first thing is the feature importances
so basically showing like which are the
input features what goes into the model
and which is the most important of
course if you ever worked with this data
you know that the
agenda of the passenger is by far the
most important variable for predicting
the survival
on the titanic and which makes sense
because because
women and children went first on the on
the
on the lifeboats uh but also what's up
for example is important is the
passenger class like the first class
tickets
had a higher chance to survive age the
older you were the less likely you were
you were to survive etc
uh so these are the most important
features in this model
um then you can investigate the model
performance of course
when you have a model you want to put
into production you need to convince
some people that it's actually
working and uh it has a
high enough performance that we put into
production um
so in this case you get all your you
know standard data science
um metrics uh but also there's a whole
bunch of different plots showing
the performance of your of your model
and you can usually adjust the cutoff uh
uh
for these different graphs if you have
the area area under curve graphs
and lift curves etc so it's all all
basically different graphs and ways
of telling a story around why your model
is better than random basically and is
good enough to be deployed into
production okay so this is explaining
why the model is good enough to be used
and then often when we talk about with
when we talk about explaining models
what we really mean is are you able to
explain individual predictions are you
able to explain to a customer to a
citizen
uh like why the model had its prediction
it did and then why you acted
based on that based on that prediction
uh the way you did
so the way to get that is simply by
looking at this
individual predictions tab uh where you
can get for any kind of
for any a random passenger on a titanic
or you can select one
specifically if you wish you can get the
the
the prediction of the model and then a
breakdown
of every single feature in your model
how it affected the final prediction
so here we have mr
lindell who had a probability of
surviving according to the model of
about 18 and a half percent
and who indeed did not survive
unfortunately but then here we can have
a breakdown of why the model thinks that
mr lindell had
had such a poor chance of surviving uh
so the final prediction was eighteen and
a half percent
uh which is largely due to the fact that
mr lindell is a mister
so he's male and all mills onboard the
tannic were less likely to survive
uh then another important feature is
that the
deck uh he was staying at is unknown um
and finally he is the passenger class is
third class
and third class passengers are also less
likely to survive and so you can add up
all the features and all the different
the contributions of each feature which
then finally add up to the final
prediction of 18 and a half percent
uh likelihood of survival uh
on the right here you see a
partial dependence plot where you can
see like what if mr lindell had been
female
in which case uh uh for example uh the
likelihood of survival would have been
53 percent so you can uh you can have a
look at
this plot uh for each input feature and
you can see like if this feature was
different
how would the prediction change uh
you can also do that for multiple
features at the same time in the what-if
plot
where you can basically change all the
features uh
let's have a look at mr lindell again
here he is and let's say
mr lindell uh was not a mr lindell by
the mrs lindell how would it change
as we already saw the change of survival
goes up a lot
let's see we know that he was on on the
a deck um
let's say he wasn't third class but
first class
uh you can see that the awesome survival
really go up a lot
uh uh with each change that we make here
so this really allows you to explore
uh for a specific a passenger or
specific case or civic citizen
okay how would the model have behaved if
you were different than you were or
data on you was different than it is um
then another thing uh when we talk about
explaining a model is kind of
uh overall how much does a feature
impact the prediction
so it is called feature dependence so
how does the
feature impact predictions for all
possible values
of that feature and so here for example
we have our most important variable
[Music]
gender and then we see the impact where
the gender takes
a female or male as the um
as a value and of course we know that if
a gender is female then you're more
likely to survive if male
you're less likely to survive but you
can have a look at that for example also
at fair so here you can see that
the higher the price of the ticket that
you paid the more likely you were to
survive you can even look at feature
interactions so you can basically break
down the
contribution of each feature into a
direct effect and into an
indirect effect and then you can explore
those indirect effects to kind of see
what kind of feature interactions are in
your model especially if you use
something like a random forest or
decision tree that this usually allows
for really rich interactions
so it's very interesting to kind of
explore those and finally
it's very nice to basically show people
what the model actually is and what it's
doing so in this case we fitted a random
forest model
which is simply a collection of
different decision trees
of which you take the average um so we
can just take
let's take our friend mr
uh lindell again uh and here you see
every single
decision tree in the random forest uh
which as we know now
uh added up to an average of about 18
and a half uh but you can see like some
decision trees are actually much more
confident
and that miss lindell would survive and
some decision trees were much less
confident
but then of course random four simply
takes the average uh
so you but you can only see the the
prediction of every single city tree and
actually see a tree itself
so if you click on any given tree you
see here the path
through the fruit for the tree
for mr lindell and you can actually also
uh
draw out the entire decision tree uh so
here
this is decision tree number 17 and you
can see here the path that mr lindell
took down this tree
so this is a random forest if if we
would have fitted a
[Music]
actual boost model we could have done
the same thing and also inspected every
single
decision tree however then of course an
actually boost model doesn't take the
average of the trees but it simply adds
up all the individual trees where each
individual trees only has a small
contribution to the final decision um
so that's it that's an explainer
dashboard and that's how easy
it is to build one and to uh run one uh
so
let's go back and have a look at like
why would you need such it's
such a dashboard and how and how may
may it make your work easier hopefully
so one of the reasons why you would
actually want such a tool is because
machine learning is not just used
for optimizing clicks anymore
actually it gets used more and more
inside the
public sector and other regulated
sectors such as finance
uh and so it's actually being used to
make real decisions about real people
which might have a large impact on them
um
and so it actually becomes more and more
important to kind of understand
what these models are doing uh when you
when you're being used in production so
one of the one of the two one of the
ways that machine learning models get
used
within government the public sector is
for example in helping recommending the
right services to the right citizens
so this is very useful like you want to
really target your
your your benefits and your services
to the right people who really need it
and so it can be really useful to use
machine learning
to do this another another way it's
being used within government is to
prioritize cases like if you only have
resources
to
have to call ten percent of your citizen
to offer them a certain service
like which uh which 10 percent are going
to call actively
uh so it's very useful to know okay like
which citizen would be them
would be those who most likely need this
help so you can start to argue them
more efficiently and finally another use
case is simply
detecting fraud like you're working with
not tax payer money
so it is important to be able to spot
fraud
and using the pathway detection
[Music]
methods of machine learning can really
help in this and so this is another area
where you can use machine learning but
also maybe it can be problematic here to
use
use algorithms so often you hear this
and this this throat that these
algorithms are just
basically black boxes that will spit out
a prediction
but nobody really knows what's going on
inside them i don't think it's really
true anymore
but this is this one one of one of the
worries about using machine learning
algorithms
in a public sector so we know that
machine learning algorithms can be
extremely powerful in finding and
exploiting patterns to predict outcomes
which naturally begs the question uh
which pattern is it using is the right
patterns
and should be worried about like which
pattern patterns actually finding the
data
to make such accurate predictions um
and this and the and the fact that
people feel that they don't know exactly
what this model is doing
then it generates fear
uh so this models you know if you have a
random forest model or an actually boost
model
can consist of dozens or even hundreds
of decision trees may even be by large
decision trees or deep decision trees
uh or if you build and they're on that
this might be even
millions or nowadays even billions of
parameters
and so then people fear okay what is
this black box actually doing
um and so if you want to get these mods
into production it's very important
that you're able to convince people that
what your model doing is innocuous
uh you're not uh selecting people based
on gender
or or ethnic um
ethnic background uh you're using
features that are reasonable to use
for your specific application and so in
order to build trust uh
it really helps if you can open the
black box and show people exactly what
the model is doing and especially what
it's not doing
um so in order in order to build trust
you need to basically
be able to show and explain your model
uh to stakeholders at all levels uh so
in
in the first place of course you as a
data scientist
yourself have to be really confident
that you understand what the model is
doing
because that gives you the confidence
and then to go out and say okay we
should use this model and it's
using the right things in the right way
but then you need to be able to explain
to you to your managers what the model
is doing and
it can be trusted then you need to
explain from to the manager managers and
do the manager manage managers
all the way up to the minister maybe or
to the head of your agency
um so you need to find a way to convince
those non-tactical people as well
then you might have internal regulators
inside
your organization uh for example the
legal department and which may need to
be convinced that uh what you're doing
uh follows all the
you know all the national regulations
uh and if you have such recognition such
regulations
you might also have an external
regulator that's interested in exactly
what you're doing
with your models and finally of course
you have outsiders such
as cities themselves who maybe have a
right to an explanation
if they get selected for example based
uh uh
based upon a machine learning algorithm
um
so all these people are not highly
technical but they still
have a right to be explained what this
model exactly does
and so for that we need to open the
black box
um so as i mentioned for data scientists
i think this
this problem is mostly solved like these
models are actually not black boxes
and nowadays we have tools such as shaft
values line values partial dependence
plots
to really show what like what the model
is doing and how different features
impact predictions
even individual predictions um
however in order to kind of generate
these kind of plots uh uh any kind of
explanations usually we have to be a
data scientist who's fluent in in
python notebook
etc in order to generate uh any
destinations
uh so the next step is actually uh
um using these tools and building tools
around it so it actually becomes also
easy for
all the stakeholders around it such as
managers internal regulators external
regulated citizens
to use these tools in an interactive and
accessible way
so that is basically the goal of this
explainer dashboard package so to make
it easy for data scientists to build
explainer dashboards
hopefully you've seen that it only took
two lines of code and then it should be
easy for stakeholders to use the
dashboard without involvement of a data
scientist like they could just click
around
and it should be easy for organizations
to get these explainer dashboards
uh deployed uh so whenever you have an
external regulator interested in your
model
you can simply point them to your
running a dashboard and they can go
inspected the model uh
by themselves uh so that's
that those are basically in a nutshell
the reasons why you would want such an
explainer dashboard however the
dashboard that i just showed you i had
like
seven tabs and a lot of different
components and each component a lot of
different
toggles and drop-downs so that might be
a bit overwhelming to simply show to
your manager
so often a lot of cases you would want
to build your own custom explainer
dashboards
and luckily this is also quite easy to
do using explainer dashboard package
let's have a look how that is done all
right so we want to build our own
custom explainer dashboard so let's have
a look at how that's done
uh so the thing that makes it easy uh
relatively easy is that all the
components
that you've seen so far on this default
explainer dashboard is actually an
independent component
uh so you can actually use those in your
own designs in your own layouts
and just put whatever text or other
explanation around it and you can
use whatever
components you think are most useful to
your specific project so for example uh
we saw this
[Music]
and the panel's component which is a
single component you can reuse in your
inside your own
inside your own dashboard so
if you go into the documentation uh for
player dashboard
uh you can find the whole list of all
the components
uh such as are there so if you go look
for here for the
dependence component as one here uh you
can see that you know
like when you build the instance of the
shaft depends component you can
pass parameters to hide the different
[Music]
toggles and drop-downs
of the of the
component and you and you can also pass
default values uh for the different
parameters
uh and then you can simply uh put it in
put it put it
inside your own layout uh however first
we're gonna have a look at how you can
actually access these these these
explainer components inside a jupyter
notebook
uh so you can actually play around with
them interactively in your jupyter
notebook
so that we use inline explainer
which also wraps around your explainer
object and then we can simply call
uh the shep
dependence component here so here you
have example of the component actually
running interactively inside
inside
the notebook however as we said we have
a lot of toggles here
some of them we might want to get rid of
so we can get rid of those
by simply saying hide those different
toggles
so if you then run it again we have a
much simpler component here with only
two drop downs for
the feature and uh whatever feature
you'd like to color
the feature by uh or not at all um
okay so now here we have a component so
let's see how we can build a layout
around this component or multiple
components
uh so we do that by defining a custom
dashboard layout
uh which we're gonna do here so first we
need to need some import so we need to
import all the explainer components
and then we simply define a layout as
part of a class
so we have a layout method that returns
a layout
which can which consists of
bootstrap elements and html elements and
then the actual components that you want
to include
so in order to include a component in
your layout you first need to define it
in the init
so here are the the three components
we'd like to include
a precision component a shape summary
component and a shape dependence
component and then we can define here
like which toggles we would like to hide
in the final layout
and then in order to define your layout
you simply define
a number of rows and columns and then in
each column you can define for example
some some headers
or some text that you'd like to display
and uh in the location
in which you would like to see your
component you simply
insert the layout of your component uh
so we can do that for our precision
component for our sharp
summary component and our ship depends
component
and and then on and then on the side of
these components we have some
some some some
actual explanation of this component uh
so it will be a very nice way to get an
overview of the model
then if we also like to have another tab
available to us basically shows
individual predictions and explains
those
uh but only keep it simple so we only
have one one component
with the contributions
uh uh of of these predictions like which
features generated
uh uh uh which part of the final
prediction
and we wanna visualize the whole forest
of individual trees
inside the random forest um then
and then this tab is even simpler in
terms of layout we simply have
three rows each row has a single column
and in each column we simply have uh one
of these one of these
[Music]
i want these components with a header uh
so this is our second tab and in order
now to build this dashboard
um it's very simple we simply pass
a list of custom tabs uh to explain your
dashboard
and uh it will run it for us we can also
pass a nice title
we want to add on what we want to add on
the top and you can even add
themes so in this case we use the flatly
theme
which uh i might look slightly nicer
than the default theme
depending on your preference so if you
open this now
here we have it this is our new
and a custom dashboard
especially built uh for this model uh so
you can see the
the the application plot with the text
going with it
uh the feature importances uh either
aggregate or in detail
uh with the text going with it and then
here the feature impact
plot uh and our individual predictions
can be seen here so here you can select
any of
the passengers uh uh with the
contributions to the prediction
and every single tree in the random
forest okay so that is how easy it is
to build your own custom explainer
dashboard so i hope that will
that will help you in building your own
dashboards that are simple
clean and beautiful and that will
convince your management and your
stakeholders
and to go ahead with this beautiful
model that you built uh to help
the citizens in your own country okay so
that was it for me
um i hope this was useful i hope you got
the kind of flavor of like
why it's important and useful to have
this kind of
explainable ai dashboard and how easy it
is to build one
and also how easy it is to build your
own custom version of it
which will hopefully be easier to
present to your two stakeholders
if you want to try it out here below you
can find all the information to install
the package
and if you build something cool please
let me know
get get in touch otherwise i wish you a
lot of fun building your own explainer
dashboards